qui pourrait aussi profiter de ses
déplacements en europe de l'est pour se
rendre en ukraine on retrouve sur place
à kiev notre envoyé spécial pauline
godard bonjour pauline est ce qu'on en
sait davantage sur la très probable
venue d' emmanuel macron à kiev
écoutez c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
spéculation et 6,1 sur cette potentielle
visite d' emmanuel macron à kiev le
président français ne s'est toujours pas
rendu en ukraine il est donc plutôt
attendu ici d'autant que le président
français est à la tête de la présidence
de l'union européenne et ce jusqu'à fin
juin il est vrai que volodymyr zelensky
le président et ses conseillers ont
appelé à plusieurs reprises emmanuel
macron à venir ici en ukraine avant la
fin la fin de cette présidence de
l'union européenne et puis après la
vague de critiques et notamment
d'incompréhension à kiev après la
déclaration qu'avait fait emmanuel
macron en disant qu'il ne voulait pas à
humilier la russie qu'il ne fallait pas
humilier la réussit bien le président
français a rappelé depuis la roumanie il
y à quelques heures je cite la clarté de
la position française de soutien à
l'ukraine sans aucune complaisance à
l'égard de moscou est-ce qu'en faisant
cette déclaration emmanuel macron est en
train peut-être semble-t-il de préparer
un petit peu le terrain si bien sûr il
vient ici à kiev en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que la popularité des manuels
macron est loin d'être aussi grande que
celle de boris johnson le premier
ministre britannique
pauline à un mot peut-être de la
situation sur le terrain les ukrainiens
le répète il leur faut des armes est
vite il ya urgence un l'armée montrent
des signes de faiblesse dans le donbass
quelles sont les nouvelles du front est
écoutez oui en effet c'est une
déclaration qui est fait quasi et chaque
jour ici sur ce manque d'armes à
severodonetsk que voici les dernières
nouvelles que nous avons 1 70% de la
ville est pour l'instant aux mains des
troupes russes les soldats ukrainiens se
sont retirés du centre ville de nombreux
soldats sont actuellement retranchés
dans l'usiné azote il y a également deux
nombreux civils ces informations
également été confirmée ce matin par le
ministère de la défense britannique il
ya donc environ 1 500 civils qui sont
bloqués la russie a annoncé hier qu'elle
voulait mettre en place aujourd'hui un
couloir humanitaire de 7h à 19h heure
française pour pouvoir évacuer ces
civils vers des zones contrôlées par les
russes pour le moment on n'a pas plus
d'informations à savoir est-ce que ce
couloir humanitaire a été ouvert ou pas
rien a été infirmée rien n'a été
confirmé puis la russie avait également
posé une condition il fallait que les
soldats ukrainien déposent les armes
pour l'instant il faut quand même
retenir et comprendre que cette
situation ressemble bien à celle de
marioupol à l' usine d'azov staël ou est
également des civils avaient été bloqués
pendant de nombreuses semaines de
nombreuses fois la russie avait annoncé
vouloir mettre en place des couloirs
humanitaires et de mon de nombreuses
fois tout ça ne s'était pas concrétisée
ce sont donc des adam des annonces à
prendre avec énormément de précautions
pauline godey envoyé spécial france 24
avec catherine norris trent et wassim
ben ali merci à vous